- Good afternoon everyone.
I'm Tomiko Brown-Nagin,
the Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
I'm so happy to see you
today and to welcome you
to today's Kim and Judy Davis
dean's lecture in the arts.
This event is part of a series
established by Kim and Judy
Davis to feature leading
artists, scholars,
and scientists in public
talks here at Radcliffe.
I'm so glad to see Kim
Davis in the audience today.
Kim, thank you so much
for your generous support.
I'd also like to
acknowledge and thank
members of the Radcliffe
Institute Leadership Society
and all of our
dedicated annual donors.
Thank you.
This afternoon's
program features
Xu Bing, a prolific
and versatile artist
working at the
forefront of Chinese
and global contemporary art.
Xu has presented his work,
which includes mixed media
installations,
prints, and sculptures
and recently film at major
venues around the world,
including here at Harvard.
I'm thrilled to welcome
Xu back to campus.
In installations of often
all unsparing scale,
Xu's art confronts us with the
instability of our perceptions
and our assumptions.
As it does so,
Xu's art addresses
some of the
fundamental challenges
of contemporary society--
the precarious connections
between language and truth,
the difficulties of translation
across cultural and linguistic
boundaries, and the status
of the image in an era
of omnipresent surveillance.
Let me share just
a few examples.
Perhaps Xu's most
iconic work is Book
from the Sky, a monumental
installation that
complicates the relationship
between tradition, authority,
and meaning.
This work earned Xu
international acclaim,
including a MacArthur
Foundation Genius award.
Created over four years
and finished in 1991,
Book from the Sky features
books, hanging scrolls,
and wall panels, all
of which Xu produced
using traditional Chinese
block carving, typesetting,
and book binding techniques.
While Book for the Sky
invites reading, no part of it
can actually be read.
This is because the
text features thousands
of glyphs that closely
resemble Chinese characters
but have been carefully
designed to be
devoid of semantic meaning.
By drawing us in this
way, Book from the Sky
exposes the fragility
of perception
and of the written word itself.
We're left to wonder how much
our habitual acts of reading
and recognition rely only
on surface level appearance.
Xu's art also addresses the
relationship between meaning
and translation and how a
work impacts one audience
differently from another.
For example, in Square
Word Calligraphy,
Xu developed a system
of creating pictograms
of written English words that
resemble Chinese characters.
To English language
readers these pictograms
appear indecipherable but are
perfectly readable upon closer
inspection.
By contrast to Chinese
readers, the characters
might seem legible
at first glance
but they are in
fact indecipherable.
In another series of works
titled Background Story,
Xu explores recognition
and misrecognition
in visual traditions.
He presents what seem
to be traditional ink
paintings of landscapes, but
as viewers approach the works,
they come to see
that each painting is
in fact a shadow and light
box insulation created
from carefully arranged
trash and natural debris.
And finally, Xu's reset feature
length film, Dragonfly Eyes,
which the Harvard film archive
screened yesterday evening,
continues his career
long exploration
of meaning and perception
in a fascinating new format.
In just a few minutes,
we'll hear directly from Xu.
He'll present brief
remarks and then
engage in a discussion with
two Harvard faculty members
on the full range of
his work, its impact
on contemporary arts, and
the overarching question what
counts as art today.
Throughout his
distinguished career,
shoos Xu has pushed boundaries
of what's considered fine art.
He's received numerous awards,
including the MacArthur Genius
Grant that I mentioned
earlier and a medal of arts
from the US State Department.
Currently, he serves as a
professor at the Central Art
Academy of Fine Arts in Beijing
and as the Andrew DY Professor
at Large at Cornell University.
Xu's conversation
partners this afternoon
are Jennifer Roberts
and Eugene Wang.
Jennifer is the
Johnson-Kulukundis family
faculty director of
arts here at Radcliffe
and the Elizabeth
Cary Agassi professor
of the humanities in the
faculty of Arts and Sciences.
Eugene is the Abby Aldrich
Rockefeller Professor
of Asian Arts in the FAS, as
well as a former Radcliffe
Fellow.
I'm delighted to have
both of them here today.
Now please join me in warmly
welcoming Xu Bing to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Thank you, Dean Brown-Nagin,
for your introduction.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- The fact that Harvard
invited me to give this talk,
I feel like I have to
thank a lot of people.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- We also have to thank Mr. Kim.
- And also professor Eugene Wan.
He did a lot for this event.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- As well as Professor Roberts.
- And a lot of other people,
of course, but mostly I
want to thank everyone
for coming today.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So today, , mainly we're going
to be engaging in a dialogue.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But before doing
that, I thought
that I would take 15 minutes to
give you a brief introduction
to my works.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because I'm not that famous,
so there's a lot of my works
that maybe a lot of you
aren't familiar with.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So actually currently at
the Ullens Center in Beijing,
I have a relatively
large exhibition
that's going on right now.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- This exhibition is exhibiting
about 40 years worth my work.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So after doing
this exhibition,
I started to think about what is
it exactly that an artist does
with his life?
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So I discovered that actually
what an artist is doing
his entire life is
creating a kind of insular
or insulated a garden or
a courtyard of himself.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So within this garden, an
artist work, his previous work,
his current work,
it's continually,
sort of, mutually
re-activating and triggering,
stimulating each other.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So for example, there are
elements of your earlier work
that in later works it kind
of comes to the forefront,
and people only realize
after seeing your later work
that actually the
same elements already
existed in your earlier work.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But this type of thing only--
is only implicated
through later work.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Even though formally
speaking earlier work
might be really different
from later work,
but actually earlier work
serves as a commentary
or interpretation of later work.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- I started off
learning printmaking,
and I received my education in
the People's Republic of China.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- I wanted to briefly
first introduce this.
This work is called a
five series of repetition.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So what this word is I was
examining the repetitive nature
of print-making.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So I've always been, sort of,
examining why does print-making
exist as an art form and
alongside things like oil
painting and other
forms of painting.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So it's the same block, but
on the left this was before
anything had been carved .
And then the middle it's when
a few things had been carved.
And then later more
things have been carved.
And this was-- this
is the same block,
but it was all printed in a
series on a piece of paper.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And I continue to carve
and continue to print.
It's actually all
just one block.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Though in normal conception,
the one on the left
should be what we consider
a completed print.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But I continue to carve.
- And then the images
start to disappear.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And so in the end it becomes
a work where there's nothing
there and just white.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So it's a process
of transforming
from a black nothingness
to a white nothingness.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this type of
plurality is something
that I think has
a special power.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- It's the same reason why the
New York Times, for example,
has such power, because
it has this plurality.
It has this series
repetitive nature.
That's why it can be
distributed around the world.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- That's why cell phones,
for example, today--
cell phone interfaces
have such power,
because they can be
endlessly repeated.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So contemporary society has
a particular characteristic,
which is that it takes us
into this space where things
are endlessly reproduced.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- A lot of Avant
Garde disciplines
when they go into this
Avant Garde sort of area,
it all has to do with repetitive
nature, including biology.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- This is a Book of the
Sky, which dean has already
introduced.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- This was an
installation, but it was
composed of many, many words.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- These words look a lot
like Chinese characters,
but there isn't a single one of
them that can be actually read.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And I was very
assiduous about this,
so every single character
was hand-carved and printed.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because I wanted this
book to have a lot of,
sort of, gravitas so that
people, when they read it,
they wouldn't be able to
believe that all this effort
and it becomes a book
that you can't read.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So in 1990, I came
to the United States
and my work then was all
slightly smaller installations.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But then I realized
wherever you live
and wherever a problem exists
that there art exists to.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So back then a
lot of my work had
to do with language and
culture and the clash
between languages and cultures.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- For this work I used something
that was written by a Columbia
professor, and then
I asked someone
to translate it into English.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And then from English,
then it was translated
into other languages--
French, Italian.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And then from that
language translated
into German and other languages.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And then into
Japanese and other types
of languages, so basically just
endless series of translation
and then at the very
end back into Chinese.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So at that time I was trying
to investigate this sort
of cultural misunderstanding.
How does that happen?
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- This was in the
year 2000 at the MOMA.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So actually because this was
introduced just now earlier you
already know how to read this.
- A-R-T F-O-R T-H-E P-E-O-P-L-E.
- People.
Art for--
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And this idea actually came in
1993 and '94, and then later I
also turned the gallery
into an art classroom.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So finally when you actually
try to write these characters,
you realize that these
characters that look
like Chinese calligraphy, oh,
actually, I can read them.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So for this classroom
I created a textbook,
and it looks like it's
a Chinese textbook
but actually it's
an English one.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this is a early sketch.
It shows how I went from
the alphabet to the strokes.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- This is me experimenting
with whether or not
I could create a character
for the longest English word
possible.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So actually it's
all a group, so it
goes from the top to
bottom from left and right.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So then I became
a calligrapher,
and a lot of people asked me
to write different things.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So actually this
particular work
has a commonality with all
the rest of my work, which
is that I always
really like to push
the way we think, the way
people think into a corner,
into a dead end.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And in this corner, all of
our old ways of thinking--
they don't function anymore.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So for example, we have ideas
or concepts about what makes--
what is English?
What is Chinese?
But with this type of
calligraphy, neither of those
function.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because when
you're writing this,
you really don't
know whether you're
writing English or Chinese.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So next there was a work
called Book from the Ground.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this book was written with
emojis, icons, punctuation.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- It's actually a story
book that narrates
a person's life in 24 hours.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- You can try to read it.
Someone woke up.
He went to the bathroom.
- And he couldn't
make it, right.
- But he was constipated.
- In the thinking, the problem,
my stomach has problem,
and then he feel
[INAUDIBLE],, right.
He's a play the--
- Social media.
- Oh, social media.
Now he's finished, right.
So I mean, even looking back
then the flash, yeah, flash.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- This was collected
from airplane bathrooms.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So none of these icons,
none of these emojis,
I didn't design
any of them myself.
I just collected them.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because it was my
belief that only collected
icons or emojis had this
sort of essence of language.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because it was the extent
of globalization these days.
It's like a new type of
pictograph is emerging.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this is the exact
opposite or inverse
of the Book from the Sky,
because that one no one
could read it and this
one everyone can read it.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- These two books were-- these
two works were very different
but they have one
thing in common,
which is that they
treat everyone equally.
They're equal to everyone.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- They both go beyond
our preconceived cultural
hierarchies.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this is from the Ullens
Center where I had my exhibit.
What I did was we moved--
we basically recreated
what my workshop
looked like when we were
creating Book from the Ground.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So the material, the raw
material for this project
grew and grew, because
actually what I like to do
is I like to use materials that
are in the process of becoming,
that are in the
process of growing.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So we also did
all of the software
where you can input
English or Chinese
and then icons come out.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- This was something
that was at the MOMA--
an exhibit that was at
the MOMA a few years ago.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So for me I like to take
one theme, a one thing idea,
and repeatedly explore it.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this was--
we used this to
create a pop up book.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- He's actually--
the function of--
the function of folks has
been replaced by touchscreens.
So actually physical books they
are very important in the sense
that they preserve this
tactile sort of feeling.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this story at this point
is talking about a guy getting--
he got drunk at the bar and
his friend is taking him home,
but the friend
can't find his keys.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE] So
- This is from a project
called Where the Dust,
where does the
dust itself settle.
And that the previous picture
was a picture from outside
of my workshop, my office,
and my studio in New York.
And I witnessed the
twin towers falling.
And as an artist, you don't
know how to cope with that.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So then I went downtown and
I collected a bag of dust,
because at that time all
of the lower Manhattan
was covered in dust.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So we took the dust and
blew it onto the exhibit--
exhibition hall.
And then after we did that,
we took away the stencils.
And then what remained
were two lines of words.
- As there is nothing from
the first, where does the dust
itself collect?
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
- This is a seventh century zen
saying, Chan saying from China.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And next this work is
called Background Story.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- This is a new work
that's also being shown
at the Ullens Center right now.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- This painting that we
see is actually a painting
that doesn't really exist.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- It's actually the
result of us adjusting
the lighting and
the space behind it,
and then the painting shows
itself on the surface in front.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- We made this glass
into this frosted glass.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this is a painting
from Zhang Daqian.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But it was constructed using
different colored plastic bags.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- This was at the Beijing
Plastic Collection Center.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So a lot of
factories in Beijing
have now been turned
into art institutions.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So using the plastics there
I reproduced a blue green--
traditional Chinese blue
green landscape painting.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So actually classical Chinese
blue green landscape painting
was actually almost
like a warning
to us today that, actually,
we can use plastic bags
to create the same thing.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- This is just some detailing.
- So actually the
painting that we
see before us isn't on paper.
It's not an oil painting either.
It's not really a painting
that exists materially.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So in my artwork, what I
really like to do is I like
to work very hard to create a
type of reality that's actually
an illusion that doesn't--
it doesn't actually exist.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this was created
using 660,000 cigarettes.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So if someone smokes two
packs a day, in 45 years
this is how many he
would be smoking.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this was actually
a touring exhibition.
So it went to Virginia,
went to different places.
And actually every place
that it exhibited at
had a history with tobacco.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And at every location based
on the history of tobacco
there that there was a
new work that was created.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this is, sort
of, tiger skin design.
It's very interesting.
From one place you look at it,
it looks like a tiger skin.
But you walk to the other end,
and it looks like a zebra skin.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And next there was
a work called Phoenix.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this was very large.
This is my first work
after I got back to China.
Each one was 30 meters long.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because in China
everything's huge.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Well, actually the
World Financial Center
commissioned this work.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But when he arrived at
the construction site,
he was very deeply impacted by
the situation of the workers.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So then I thought would it be
possible to take the, sort of,
scraps left from
construction and the tools
that construction
workers use and use
that to create a work that
would hang in this big new--
brand new building.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So actually hidden within
a lot of these materials
were LED lights so
that when night falls
you can see the lights.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But because in
China, as you know,
everything is always
changing, and then we
had the Beijing Olympics.
And then after that there
was a global economic crisis.
And then basically
the people who
commissioned it
no longer thought
that art was so important.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So then they looked at him and
said, oh, this work, kind of,
looks incomplete.
Shouldn't you,
like, maybe in case
it in Crystal or something.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So in the end, this work
was not hung in that building,
and so it, kind of,
toured around the world.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this is in New
York in a cathedral.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And then it went to Venice.
- So Venice at night
is very beautiful.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But not a lot
of people saw it,
because in Venice
things close at 7:00 PM.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But this was
the very last part
of my exhibition at
the Ullens Center.
And so each of these computers
show a contemporaneous footage
from surveillance cameras.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Including surveillance
footage from the museum itself.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So just a brief introduction
then to Dragonfly Eyes,
which will take up the
majority of conversation today.
And I'll just show a
two minute trailer.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This is dragonfly.
Dragonfly has 28,000 eyes
blinking 40,000 times
per second.
Hour by hour, checking.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Second by second, deleting.
- Searching, identifying.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Scenes, roles, characters.
- This is a man.
He will be seen
300 times each day.
This is a woman.
Her privacy is all used up.
The man and the woman meet.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- He and she leave data.
- A lay Buddhist.
A non-believer?
[CRASH]
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This is a narrative
fiction film.
And the film is 81 minutes long.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- What's special about this
film is that every frame of it
really happened.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- It's different from any
fiction film that we have
watched before,
because fiction--
all other fiction
films are fabricated.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So considering time,
maybe we should move on
to the conversation.
But it is true, in fact,
that all of my previous work
has a very intimate relationship
with Dragonfly Eyes.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- This is I consider
an artwork of mine,
and basically I use
the format of a film.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So basically I like to--
this is what I like to do with
my work.
I like to work really
seriously doing something,
and then what I'm
actually trying to say
is not actually the
thing that I made.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- For example, with
this film there's
no way for us to really
judge is this a documentary
or is this a narrative film.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because it's more
real than a documentary.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because with documentaries
what you're doing often
is can you just repeat
what happened or you
interview someone
or you say, oh,
can you walk through
that door one more time.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So within that-- inherent
in that is an unrealness.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So we screened
that film yesterday.
I'm sure everyone has
a lot of questions.
So let's proceed on
to the discussion.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Thank you.
That was wonderful.
Once again, thank you to
everyone for coming today.
I want to extend a
very special thanks
to Joy Chen who is our
translator and interpreter
this evening.
[APPLAUSE]
As we've seen so
much of Xu Bing's art
contends with complexities of
translation, so it's actually,
I think, wonderful
that we have a chance
to experience this
in an embodied way
tonight in this discussion.
So thank you so much, Joy.
So we have about--
why don't we ask
questions, and we'll
talk for about 15 or 20 minutes.
And then we'll move to
questions from the audience.
And maybe I'll start.
Many of us are, I
think, still reeling
from the incredible screening
of Dragonfly Eyes last night
at the Harvard Film Archive.
And thanks to the Harvard
Film Archive and its director
Haden Guest for arranging this.
I wanted to ask Xu if
you could say something
about your discovery and use of
facial recognition technology
in surveillance
video, which I imagine
must have been extremely
important for you
both because so
much of your work
seems to be about recognition
and the difficulty
of recognizing or that moment
when a form snaps into meaning
in a particular reader
or viewer's mind.
And that also so much of your
prior work has to do with,
as you've put it, the
semiotic and schematic quality
of Chinese art and images.
And just yesterday
in the print room
you had said that
in Chinese art,
the character for a tree
and an image for the tree
are the same.
And throughout your film, we
have these video images that
are being rapidly labeled--
automatically labeled by
the recognition technology.
So I wonder if you could just
talk a little bit about how
you've used that, how
it came into the film,
and how it worked.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So it took about five years
for us to make this film,
and within these five years,
surveillance technology
was continually, sort of,
improving and developing.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So as an artist,
I really wanted
to make sure that every frame we
used was surveillance footage.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So you have the idea
that in two years, sort of,
those devices in cars that
record what's happening
within the car, those appeared.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And then body
cams that cops wear.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Go Pro, the Go
Pro that you wear.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And then with the advent
of these technologies,
it changes our previous
conception of surveillance.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because in the past,
surveillance was,
kind of, stationary
in one place.
But now surveillance moves
as well, moves with us.
It has to do with our bodies.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And then towards the
end, facial recognition
developed very rapidly.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So you can see
that in our film,
there are many layers,
different ways of treating
this very complicated
phenomenon that's
happening in our society.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So it's almost like a Chinese
Theater or a Chinese drama.
You have these twists
and turns, and it's
like using this technology
to try to parse out
the different elements.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So then that's why we
use this, sort of, square
and the search function and
then that is accompanied
by a computer's voice.
And this computer's
voice has a, sort of,
a dumbed-down quality to it.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So it says things
like man, woman, car.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But we discovered that
this type of simplicity
actually shares something
with classical Chinese poetry
or Japanese haikus.
- OK, Xu Bing, welcome
back to the Harvard.
You've been here
a number of times,
and each time is a quite
meaningful experience.
And so I want to just
take this occasion--
it's such a rare occasion
where I have you,
one of the most celebrated
print-makers in the world,
and also I have Jennifer
who studies prints
and one of the eminent
scholar of print.
So it's a rare occasion
that I can use your own word
to corner you or corner
your thinking to push you
to the corner I think.
So I know you.
I follow your career,
and for decades, we've
been old friends.
And one thing I
often tell people
is that as a print-maker,
Xu Bing is a control freak.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
You always want to make
sure that all the steps that
lead to the final product
should not go wrong.
I remember you were
making that how
to have the cocoon spin
out web that can eventually
cover a computer set.
That has to involve ordering
certain kind of spring worms
from Texas.
They'll come-- they have to
arrive at a certain time,
and the timing will be so
perfect so that they can spin.
So knowing you with that kind
of control freak mentality, how
you have to work with
a medium that is--
could potential get out of hand.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
Especially when this film
is a film without involving
your team taking a single shot.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
So I imagine that you would
like the fact that there
were emergent properties from
this medium or production
process.
- That he likes--
- Yeah, you like that fact.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
And that in some ways is a
departure from your earlier
printmaking self.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
And also I found this
kind of intriguing
that as a print-maker,
you use hand a lot.
And now you let your hand idle.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
Yesterday, we were in
the viewing session,
and when you demonstrate how
the carvers work their wrist,
your hand was dancing
in the air all the time.
And that was quite
amazing movement.
I can't help marveling at that.
So now it's the eye taking over.
Hand is idle.
Do you feel a sense of loss?
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Very good question,
Professor Wang.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So, in fact, I did go through
a very rigorous conservatory
training, art school training.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So my training in printmaking
was very helpful to me.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because printmaking is a
very indirect form of art.
So it requires a lot
of control to break
through the limitations
of the form.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So if you're not
particular about every step,
then the end result
will be just a mess.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But I have a
personal preference,
which is that I like to do
things that are challenging.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- If it's something that anyone
can do or everyone can do,
then it's not worth me doing it.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So even works like
the silkworm work
that you mentioned,
it looks like it's
very, sort of, spontaneous.
But actually it
acquired a lot of work.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because we had to
control it so that when
the exhibit opened,
these silk worms
are actually spinning silk.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But every type or species
of silkworm when it starts
producing silk, it's different.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So what did we do?
We had to order first a
specific species of silkworms
and then actually feed
them and let them grow
and then record when they start
producing silk and all of that.
And then use that
to do the work.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So I've exhibited
all over the world,
and basically what people say
about me is I'm too picky.
Because basically, if I
go into an installation
and I don't feel
right in the space,
then I go back and
check the measurements.
Then definitely it's always true
that they didn't adhere exactly
to the measurements.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So to a lot of people
maybe they would say,
oh, it's just a little
bit of a difference.
It doesn't matter.
But to me, it effects the
overall effect of the work.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So actually Dragonfly
Eyes has a, sort of,
internal connection to my
previous printmaking work.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So it's about
taking this limit--
a limitation and
then transforming it
into something special.
- We have just a
couple more minutes
before we move to the audience.
Perhaps, a good final
question from us
would be just to ask you
where you see your work going
now and in the future and about
how Dragonfly Eyes has perhaps
changed the trajectory
of your work.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- You can see that my work
takes a lot of different forms,
and that's because
I don't really
take art style that seriously.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because I want to say
something no one's said before.
And if I want to say it in
a proper way and a way that
really gets at it, it has
to be in an interesting way.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And the formats and
styles that the old masters
used, for example, to
express their ideas, that
was particular to their time
and what they wanted to say.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Including my own artistic
language from my older works,
I can't just co-op that
into my current work either.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because to me my art has
to do with your sensitivity
to the present moment and
then how you take old forms
and transform that using
your current sensitivity
to the contemporary society.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And it's necessarily the
case that contemporary society,
the way things are right now
within that there is more--
there are more avenues for
creativity and the more
inspiration can be found
in the present moment.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So regarding what I'm doing
next, actually, I don't know.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But I trust that I
have something to say.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because this world is
changing too quickly.
There are too many questions
that need us-- need answers.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- To me, art is not something
you get from planning.
- Very good.
OK, the magic microphone is
coming up to the center aisle.
I wanted to-- we want to
open the floor to about 15
or 20 minutes of questions.
I know many of you were at
the screening last night
and may have
questions about that.
If you do have a
question for Xu Bing,
please come up to
the microphone here.
And please identify yourself
prior to asking your question.
And we'll have questions for
15 minutes or so and then
a reception downstairs.
- No problem.
My name is Claribel Santiago.
When you lived in New York
and you witnessed personally
your journey of
9/11 and you said
that changed you as an artist,
did that change you to--
now to just focus--
not focused, but now look for
the pain of others in your art
now?
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So actually at the
time I witnessed--
I saw with my own eyes
the twin towers falling.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But actually what I thought
of in the moment was the scene
on Chang'an Street on June 4th--
the June 4th incident.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And in that moment,
I thought, wow,
from this moment on this world
is really going to change.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because when we left
Beijing back then, we had--
back then Beijing wasn't safe.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And now New York has become
a place that isn't safe.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But what really
impacted me was
when I walked out of my
building the next day,
I felt like the entire
balance of the ecosystem was--
it was all array, because
suddenly these two
big buildings were not there.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- There was an article, a
report then also of a parent
telling their child, oh, if you
can't find your way home just
look for the twin towers.
And with that, you'll be
able to find your way home.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But faced with
such an incident,
you really don't
know what to do.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But because I have this habit
of collecting raw materials,
so then I went down to the
site and collected some dust.
But actually at
that time, I didn't
know what I would do with it.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Would you like to
translate her question?
Summarize what she asked so that
the audience know what you--
your question.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So her question is
about why he didn't
include a particular work.
The English title is
like the-- is it utopia?
No, it's the--
It's the peach
blossom, but it's--
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Anyway, her question
was why did you not
include that work in
your introduction today.
Is it, because you don't see
it as being in the same vein
as the other works.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So I actually have a lot--
I have produced a lot of work,
so I already went over time.
So it wasn't possible
to include everything.
- So, hi, how are you?
So welcome to Harvard,
and I actually
saw your exhibition
in Metropolitan
and also in Beijing.
I was really honored
to have you here.
And my question is in China
actually the freedom of speech
become a little bit more
restrict in the recent years.
And as an artist,
artist want to be free
and want to have the freedom
to do whatever they want to do.
But when you are
approaching your art,
how do you have that
consideration when
you are approaching your art?
Would you like
modify it in some way
or soften the stand you
have in your art work.
The second question
is your attitude
to or your evaluation of Ai
Weiwei, which is a very--
like a political artist
and what's your attitude
to his art work and his career.
Thank you.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So it's true that China is a
very political kind of society.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But actually America
is that way too.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So as an artist, even
if you're not directly
dealing with political
things in your work,
it's always inevitable that
you have this undercurrent
of politics in your work.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So every artist has a
different personality,
and for example, Ai Weiwei is
a more direct kind of person.
So he's-- he'll deal with issues
more directly, and he'll--
he's the type of
person who wants to get
into a fight with you directly.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But other artists have other
personalities where maybe you
want to deal with problems in
a other way-- in another way.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So it's just different.
- Hi, my name's Kalis.
Thank you Xu Bing for coming to
Harvard and giving this talk.
My question is what do you think
this movie-- or what are your--
what are your thoughts
on what this movie has
to say about contemporary
Chinese society.
And like I know it
probably couldn't
be made in the United
States, and if it was,
it would be very different.
But what do you think
about this movie
makes it uniquely Chinese
and exemplifying something
about contemporary
society in China.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So actually the
target for this movie
Dragonfly Eyes is
the entire world.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because actually
our world today
has become a gigantic
camera studio.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- It's a lot like
the social imaginings
that we found in
The Truman Show.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So in this film,
I actually didn't
want to directly talk
about surveillance.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because the very fact
that someone can take solely
surveillance footage and
make a narrative film--
and make a film out of it, that
already says something about
the state of our society.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And I didn't want
to directly talk
about this kind
of Orwellian 1984.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because to me this type
of concept everyone knows.
So there is-- it's not
necessary to talk about it.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But to me what I
wanted to express
was that to me actually
we've already entered
into a post surveillance era.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because at least in China,
most of the surveillance--
the footage that's being
taken, it's all been controlled
by private companies
as well as individuals.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So actually 99 % percent
of the footage that you see
in this film, it's all
stuff that was uploaded
by individuals or by
these private companies.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So actually, the use
of surveillance footage
has really expanded into
the individual's hands,
and it has gone way beyond
what Orwell imagined in 1984.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But actually this is
something that most people don't
recognize, and actually
this is what I wanted
to talk about in the film.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE] So my
question is how do you define
the relationship and the
connection between painting
and words?
Thank you.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So in China it's true that
words and images have a very
special relationship.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So you write the
character for mountain
and you're actually
painting a mountain as well.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So it seems that these days
young people what they're
looking for is a very
direct, a very simple way
of communicating--
a way of communicating that
doesn't require much learning
preferably.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So for example, the Book
from the Ground, actually,
I had the idea for this
work about 16, 17 years ago.
But at the time not
enough emojis and icons
existed to make it.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So this type of thing
developed very quickly,
and to a certain
extent, you could
say that it really is
replacing traditional language,
traditional words.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So you can say that
the icons that you
find in Book from the
Ground, they really do
possess a very strong
language element to them.
- Xu Bing, thank you
very much for being here.
It's an honor.
My name is Paula Billups.
You spoke in your
talk about the garden
that an artist builds around
themselves so that eventually
you find that you're
surrounded by your work
and that the past
and the present
begin to speak to each other.
Now that you're
furthering your career
and you're on the other--
you're on maybe in
the middle of that,
do you feel that you can
predict what you're yet older
self will be saying to you now?
Are you still having
those conversations
between past and present?
How do you view that sense
of garden, that sense
of the circle around you?
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- In fact, this type of
feeling of speaking to yourself
is strengthened.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So actually the
cultural DNA that everyone
possesses with them is
very deeply embedded.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But when you need
it, it emerges.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Sometimes it emerges,
and it helps you.
Sometimes it's harmful to you.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So it's like, for example,
in my wood block work earlier,
printing work, I realized that
I was really interested in this,
sort of, the layout of
the earth and the way
you organize things.
And then I realized that was
because during the Cultural
Revolution I was involved a
lot of the layout of newspapers
and magazines.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So it's more like my work now,
that's the way through which I
look at my past and say, oh, so
actually those elements already
existed back then.
But I only know-- recognize it
like through my current work.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So actually in a way what
an artist ends up doing,
it's kind of faded in a way.
There's a faded quality to it.
There's a destiny to it.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So for example, say I really
like a certain style, not
my style.
But if that's not-- it that
does not belong to you,
no matter how hard you work
at it it's not going to work.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- What belongs to you even
if you try to throw it away,
it won't go.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Like when I was
making Book from the Sky
I really wanted
to make something
that would be in alignment
with contemporary Western art.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because I wanted to escape
from our socialist art.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But to go into a new art form,
I didn't know what that was.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And under those
circumstances, what you
end up producing is the most
real expression of who you are.
- Hi, thank you for coming.
My name's Indigo [INAUDIBLE],,
and I saw your Phoenixes
in New York about
five years ago.
And it's one of the
things that, like,
really just kind of blew
me away at the time.
And I think the
thing that I'm really
interested in in
all of your work
is the labor that goes
into it that I think
it's almost like hidden
by how put together
and how complete they are.
And I really wanted to know
what your, like, values
were in regards to that labor
and how it's, kind of, become
a vehicle for the
content and the ways
in which you conceptualize
that in your work.
Thank you.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So I always require
that in all of my works
the core concept has
to be very sturdy.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And once that's clear,
the core concept is clear,
then you have to give it
your all to realize it.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So like Professor Wang
mentioned earlier about
how with this new work the
hand, kind of, lays idle.
But actually it's just a
different type of labor.
It just requires maybe
the hand is not moving,
but it requires a large
amount of labor as well.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So for-- in order
to make this film,
we downloaded 11,000
hours of footage.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Because this
type of technique,
no one has ever used it before.
So we really just--
we didn't know how
to go about it.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But I trusted that
within this mass volume
of data that was being
collected locally
that we would be able to find
what we needed to tell a story.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So in the beginning,
it was almost
like we were creating libraries.
So we were categorizing things
by like a temple and then
big temple, small
temple, northern temple,
southern temple, oh, two
monks walking this way,
three monks walking that way.
And we categorized
everything like that,
because we didn't know what
footage we would need yet.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So in the process of making
the film it was a continuous
back and forth between the
editors and the screenwriters,
because sometimes you-- the
screenwriters have a really
great idea but you can't
find the material for it.
And sometimes the
editor will discover
something that
wasn't in the script
but that's really interesting.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So at the end when the
story was almost complete,
we were missing one shot.
And this one shot was shot of
a rainy night on a mountainside
and you see a car
driving by, but we
couldn't find this footage.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So first we had to check
the weather forecast.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Where is it going
to rain tonight?
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So we'd work for
so long that we
knew where we would be able
to find that sort of image,
and so we focused on
that particular spot
and waited to see
if did it really--
every morning, like,
did it rain that night?
Did a car pass by?
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- And this requires
a lot of labor.
- OK, I think we have time
for one more short question,
and then we'll move on.
- I'll keep it short.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE] So my
question was there are a lot
of intersection between
commercial opportunities
and art in China.
Art is not only limited
to galleries anymore,
but art are in shopping malls
and other commercial spaces.
So I'm just wondering what are
Xu Bing's thoughts on that.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- Art has a lot of
different functions.
So sometimes it's
to beautify a space,
and sometimes it
can be a commodity.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So sometimes I think
why is it that I'm
able to sell my artwork?
Why are collectors interested?
I mean, really, like,
a lot of my works
are just a bunch of scraps.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- But then I think maybe
what they're collecting,
what museums and collectors
are collecting is that--
is the special kind of concept
or way of thinking that is
expressed through my artwork.
- [SPEAKING CHINESE]
- So there are artists, street
artists who, sort of, paint
and sell as they go.
And that's also-- that
exists for a purpose.
And then there's
maybe other artists
who their whole life they
just sell one concept.
- OK, great we have
more time for discussion
downstairs in the reception,
which follows this event.
So it's just down in the
first floor of this building.
I want to thank, again,
Joy, Xu Bing, and Eugene.
Thank you so much, and
thanks to all of you.
[APPLAUSE]